moi j'ai passé beaucoup beaucoup de mes
vacances à arcachon mon grand père était
directeur du casino de la plage
d'arcachon
mon grand père c'était monsieur li ti
qui s'appelait mais c'était un monsieur
qui ressemblait un peu c'était un peu un
gangster à l'ancienne avec des costumes
un peu comme lino ventura
il était toujours nickel etc il y avait
je vous rappelle qu'on lui même tiré
dessus une fois à cause d'un mec qui
voulait pas qu'ils pouvaient pas rentrer
dans casino bref moi je vivais dans ce
casino est en fait le casino d'arcachon
pour ceux qui connaissent ces indices de
gros gâteau un peu comme ça on dirait le
château de walt disney et il y avait un
cinéma théâtre c'est un cinéma de
quartier d'été en fait comme on a pu
voir dans les vieux films et donc il y
avait tous les films qui passait en
français je dois dire tous mais c'est là
que j'ai découvert monty python taxi
driver mines street
les films des charlots les films avec
hedwidge fenech et tintin et on les gros
minet les films d'horreur un peu les
films de dario argento tout ça mais en
fait je m'en rendais absolument pas
compte de la chance que j'avais le porno
le soir aussi
en fait je vivais dans un cinéma de
quartier dans les années 60-70
d'arcachon donc j'ai vu beaucoup
beaucoup de films là et j'étais
absolument pas cinéphile
j'étais fils d'acteurs mais je me
rendais absolument pas compte de la
chance que j'avais et donc en fait je me
suis rendu compte que je me suis créé
énormément de références à ce moment là
parce que j'allais tout voir de manière
complètement innocente je savais pas ce
qui était bien aussi n'était pas bien je
regardais ce qu'avait donc voilà mais
des années plus tard je me suis rendu
compte à quel point cela est important
pour moi quand j'ai rencontré mathieu
kassovitz un peu avant métis et que nous
avons tourné ensemble métis je suis
tombé sur un mec de mon âge qui avaient
les mêmes références que moi et qui
était en train d'apprendre en même temps
que moi et je me rappelle d'une c'est un
moment très pour moi à ses fondateurs il
m'a dit viens voir le combo le combo le
petit écran moniteur etc il ya un truc
traîne dans le métier d'acteur quand on
prend des cours d'été rares
c'est que les acteurs doivent pas se
regarder parce que sinon il son brevet
donc moi j'avais cru ça comme un
imbécile qu'il fallait pas qu'on se
regarde fallait pas qu'on se voie il m'a
dit viens voir regarde tacle du bush la
tuerie et tout d'un coup j'ai commencé à
comprendre quelque chose qui était le
cinéma et non pas juste
l'acteur est donc en fait ça c'est pour
moi ça a été pire que tout d'un coup
j'ai commencé à entrevoir et à imaginer
mon métier comme quelque chose auquel je
voulais participer de manière active
voilà mais ça n'a rien à voir avec le
succès de l'année comme ce soir c'était
de tout d'un coup me sentir à la place
surtout l'amérique pour rester quoi
l'amérique
pour moi c'était broadway new york de
californie ça m'a jamais intéressé
c'était new york c'était spike lee
s'était mines street donc moi mon
fantasme c'était le hip hop
donc moi j'arrive j'ai 16 17 ans new
york c'est le hip hop c'est les fat
laissés sur les baskets c'est roxy c'est
séverine master flash c'est dylan
souscrite
cbis marqué ce et les cours de danse
chez steps c'est les boîtes de nuit où
j'allais bosser un petit peu plus tard
c'était ça c'était c'était c'était
alphabètes city moi je me rappelle que
j'avais 17 ans j'allais en boîte je
tombais sur andy warhol basquiat nabeul
peuple c'était ça en fait l'amérique
pour moi c'était pas le cinéma